[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to fat man I'm Batman I'm Kevin
Smith hi I'm Mark Barnard oh my God
we're back it has been a red-hot minute
and stuff to catch you up a few months
ago almost died now still here so I've
been going out on tour I've been doing a
lot of shows on the road cuz after the
heart attack I was off the road for a
little bit and stuff so it was the kind
of like I'm not dead tour for the last
month and stuff out in the world but
what did I do just recently I went to
Vegas this weekend real
spur-of-the-moment man went to the Red
Rock Casino which is like 15 minutes
away from the airport which was really
nice set up shop and worked on this
project that like I can't say anything
about but I promise you it's [ __ ]
fantastic it's not mine it's for
somebody else and it involves their IP
and stuff but when I could tell you
about it first you're gonna be like you
and then you'll go oh I get it kind of
but it is [ __ ] phenomenal so that's I
went to Vegas to do that like to just
just put myself in a room and [ __ ]
work really hard and stuff which sounds
weird you don't go to Vegas for that but
I I was like you know I'll work and then
when I'm free I'll play cards but all I
did was work I saw Tyler Heron who's the
production designer on I met him on
flash and then he works on Supergirl now
and I was like just meet me there and
I'm gonna tell you this thing that I'm
working on and you know all I do that
write it down I just need somebody to
[ __ ] say it too and he's a real good
like story person and stuff also
understands the episodic nature and
budgets of episodic television so it's I
chiefly went to Vegas for that but while
I was there I got to go see Penn &
Teller who I've seen there in Vegas yes
the great peddit a few times over the
course of my life I've seen them
I guess this was the fifth time and Penn
and for anyone who's been following this
story Penn's book presto was the one
that I started reading right after my
heart attack that I made me lose weight
he was the one that introduced me to Rey
Cronus and his just side's diet which
kicks off with two weeks of just
potatoes people mistakenly call it the
potato diet and that irritates Rey but
it was it was Penn's book that I was
like well I'm gonna [ __ ] do what Penn
did and the first two weeks man I've
dropped a bunch of weight just eaten
potatoes and stuff then the diet became
far more like vegetable based and I
couldn't [ __ ] go down that road and
stuff so now I'm watching I'm a vegan
but I couldn't eat vegetables so I'm
doing a different program so but it all
began with with Penn's book so when I
was going to Vegas I was like hey man
you guys doing the show and he was
coming to record a podcast Myles this
week so it worked out and I got tickets
we want to see the [ __ ] show number
one if you've never seen Penn & Teller
I've been watching them since you know
the first time I saw him I guess would
be on SNL back in the early 80s they did
this amazing bit captured my imagination
where they were on camera and they were
doing levitation they were standing at a
counter and they would reveal things and
then just let them go and they were
flying to the [ __ ] air and the whole
time they're doing this bit you could
hear the audience like laughing like
they were in on something that you
weren't and it was amazing as you
watched the trick you like I'm like God
how the [ __ ] they doing it there's no
strings they're just letting [ __ ] and
it's going up in the air and so by the
end of the bit like during the bit they
keep telling the audience like for the
folks at home so they know that we're
not up to anything to any trickery we're
gonna constantly yell are we live and
the audience gonna be yell yeah so they
did it for like 10 minutes it was
fantastic and then at the end of the bit
they were just dropping like think huge
things levitated first of his little
dolls and then huge like bowling balls
and [ __ ] like that camera pulls out and
turns right side up and they've been
upside down the whole [ __ ] time just
dropping [ __ ] on the floor
so right away I was like I love these
people they're so [ __ ] subversive and
so you know if you're unfamiliar with
their act Penn is the very chatty one
and Teller doesn't speak sounds awfully
[ __ ] familiar so when I whenever I go
see a Penn & Teller show it's not just
me gone oh I [ __ ] love these dudes
they're geniuses at their craft it's not
just me going like oh I [ __ ] have been
watching these guys for years so it's
nostalgic or sentimental as well like
whenever I go see them I'm like I
probably owe them a percentage of
everything I ever made particularly tell
her you know alone so I've known Penn
and met Penn and he's been on my ass me
podcasted but I've seen tell her but
I've never actually met teller so before
the show they would like come backstage
and say hi there's a for an hour before
the show Penn sits there and plays jazz
with this other guy just like the free
forms and [ __ ] like that and then after
an hour that the show begins in earnest
and stuff so he said come back you know
after the Jazz session and we'll
chitchat and stuff and so I met teller
and it was so [ __ ] up because all he
did was talk and I meet so many people
in life who were just like oh my god I
didn't know you talk to this much and
[ __ ] like that and I felt like hitting
them with the same [ __ ] line but I
had to bite my tongue because I'm like
you know you hate it when people say
that [ __ ] to you so don't say to him but
it was so weird were you having a
conversation with a guy who my entire
[ __ ] life of knowing him through his
work I've never seen him speak who
talked first or did you have this some
kind of like samurais
I gotta be honest where they did like
during the show I was watching him and
realizing that like I took a lot of my
shtick directly from him he's wonderful
at performing without [ __ ] words and
stuff so it was pretty fun to see the
show number one but number two to kind
of be backstage with the two dudes
without whom I don't get to my two dudes
probably whoa what are these Oh water
things and is that for you and I come
here hey now look at you you got him
lined up like jets and [ __ ] yeah I've
done with one you look boy bring me
another beer stack and bag him I reckon
it was a great show if you haven't seen
it I urge you to go see it and what else
do I was out there oh I [ __ ] we went
to yesterday was the opening night of
the Stanley Cup Finals between the Vegas
Golden Knights and the washing that's
yeah that's a hockey sporting event it's
one of those hockey things okay just
curious I it was so weird thanks thanks
to that I was not the only person in
Vegas wearing a hockey jersey I was
surrounded by a bunch of Jersey people
so we went to the game which was [ __ ]
spellbinding breathtaking [ __ ] hockey
game and that Golden Knights story is
pretty wonderful it's real Cinderella
like that's a brand new franchise they
got to town the thirty-first franchise
in the NHL generally speaking people
don't believe in hockey in the Sun Belt
states and stuff like like that the
Kings were out leaders they've been
doing it for years and years and years
and now of course their Cup winners and
stuff and so we can recognize that the
like aki can work in some Sun Belt
states but then people will point
something like Arizona where the Coyotes
have never quite taken hold so the Vegas
thing was always gonna be questioned and
I assume they gave Vegas like the
franchise because they're like well they
get a lot of foot traffic in Vegas and
so you know there's always somebody
traveling there so that we'll be able to
sell seats but the NHL didn't approach
it like that they said to Las Vegas or
to Nevada
we're gonna sell season tickets and you
guys have to buy them locals have to buy
them because they wanted it to be a
community team not like just you know
[ __ ] a thing for tourists to do so
Vegas never having its own professional
the athletic team embraced them in a big
bad way they oversold and boom the NHL
was like you got a franchise so right
before they start playing the season of
course is good back in October would the
shootings happen in Vegas and you know
[ __ ] the city for a moment broke
everybody's heart but the Golden Knights
I guess were very deeply involved in
like you know the going forward efforts
and stuff like that community outreach
and really bonded tightly with the
community so much so that the opening
night of their games was kind of like a
referendum on that shooting and we are
Vegas strong and like the community come
together so it's not just as simple as
like oh they're a city's got a new
hockey team this hockey team is its
heart and now I've been to many NHL
games and generally speaking the most
enthusiasm or passion you'll ever hear
from an audience bunch of fans is up
north in Canada they invented the game
the game is very much there so I've been
to a game in Edmonton where you know I
was pretty sure they'd blow the roof off
like [ __ ] there was that much power
that much energy they were that loud the
game that I went to in [ __ ] Vegas of
all places was so [ __ ] passionate so
enthusiastic it brought tears to my eyes
I had no skin in the game I'll give a
[ __ ] about the caps or the golden ice
but but the end of the game I was in for
the Golden Knights like the the
community and the team stole my heart
they are one like it's this incredible
symbiosis man and they've watched this
brand-new team who just come to town
like back in October make this amazing
run so much so that they're going after
Stanley Cup in their first year that's
unheard of and in all of [ __ ] sports
so because of that Vegas loves a winner
and stuff that team's been winning they
love their [ __ ] team so they won last
night it was [ __ ] huge it was insane
being there was being around fandom you
know here we talk about fandom all the
time and we're fans of the unreal [ __ ]
and whatnot so are they hockey's not
real it's a [ __ ] game but it's so
[ __ ] real that it gave that community
something to lean on in its darkest hour
something to come around like to join to
be together around and stuff so not only
was it just a hockey game
one level and not only was it just hey
it's a Stanley Cup final game on another
level there's the beauty and a poetry to
the story of that team in that city man
it was really special to be there for it
was something that I we were like oh she
had game ones happenin I guess we can go
do that where you do the play cards or
go to that and I was so glad we paid
through the [ __ ] nose to get tickets
like you know I called up the NHL
because I got connects and [ __ ] and look
I'm Jersey boy so literally I'm
constantly representing and [ __ ] and
I've done lots of stuff for the NHL so
you know I'm like hey I'm in Vegas can I
get tickets like we can't help you so
you know hugging that Silent Bob's chick
only goes so [ __ ] far so paid out
four tickets and they were [ __ ]
pricey tickets and you know I wasn't
like bitching about it but I was like
going [ __ ] that's well I you know
what I haven't bought hockey tickets
really all year so this takes care of
that but after that game I under paid
for those tickets like it was it was one
of the greatest games I've ever seen in
my life
so they have their next game like
tomorrow night but I can't make it out
there for that and hockey people are
wonderfully it all sports people
beautifully superstitious so a bunch of
people there when I was leaving they're
like you got to come to the next game
because we wanted it's your fault so I
was like I can't what do i how do I tell
these LA speak what do you call people
from Las Vegas Las Vegan degenerates
I just spent 10 minutes building the
community up [ __ ] gamblers I can't I
can't I love the [ __ ] Vegas strong and
deep it was it was a very very cool
night to see very very cool thing what
have you been up to I did not go to a
hockey game oh no where did I go to
Vegas mm-hmm it's funny that story
reminds me a little bit of I I am NOT an
overwhelming sport fan I like basketball
cuz I grew up playing basketball I like
football because I used to like football
but I went I like baseball for lunch
really you just go for the food right
like you you show up like oh I gotta hit
some [ __ ] and wall girl cuz it's an
agrarian sport we gotta hang out in a
field for a while we're gonna get a ball
we're gonna play catch I don't how long
is it gonna go till it's done like
there's no clock on a baseball game it
just kind of happens but I went to a
game in in Fenway in Boston okay
I'm a New Yorker we are not usually
tolerated very much in Boston we're
actively hunted when you walk into
Fenway Park good but this was this was
October 2001 okay oh yeah for the minute
where everybody was super nice to each
other for that for that amazing
honeymoon phase yeah I remember that it
was so crazy you'd walk around New York
and people would be like oh excuse me
yeah and you were like what [ __ ]
twilight zone did I step into everyone
was just nicer for read-up minute so I'm
like in Boston wearing like a Yankees
cap and not getting stomped which was
always a good thing but I remember being
an infant way and you know the
seventh-inning stretch comes and I'd
sing whatever that some things Jeff song
is is a Sweet Caroline I think so I'm
not a baseball person but I just I just
think I saw a movie with Jimmy Fallon in
it and jus Barrymore and I think that
was part of it but but in the in the
halfway between the 8th yeah they
started singing New York New York and
ironic oh because the guys who's just
after 9/11 and you cannot imagine what
it's like in Fenway Park with a bunch of
Boston people singing a new york song
right after that moment like it is it is
the like we're rallying you know
because this is the thing we have to
rally around yeah I didn't mean to bring
the room down I just had a sports story
yeah you really were trying to have a
good time here and you're like people
remember September 11th that [ __ ]
sucked so bad I mean I know we got bin
Laden but [ __ ] he got us how's it long
goddamn bro
I have not been at a sporting event I've
been I've been writing man I've been
working what you've been working on I
have also been working on a thing that I
can't really talk about that's right I
know what marks thing is a mark knows
what my thing is that sounds dirtier
than we've seen each other's things I
will say though mine is a hundred
percent blacker than your through on
every level but yes so I know what it is
and it's [ __ ] cool it's very
thrilling you've been working on I've
been working on it I've been i've been
doing notes from studios that have
thought of things that i did how now let
me ask you this yeah which i can't talk
about this i know and we'll try to have
this conversation without and again it's
not because we're like ooh we want to
keep it from you like we could get fired
essentially we're at a stage in both of
our projects where if we [ __ ] it up
they'd be like bye Felicia
so so you know there's a there's a time
in place but you know you want to be
able to share in its content and you're
like when you do as many Boggess as I do
it's like it's tough to not talk about
something that that's taking up that
much time your life
so my question to you is this yes the
thing that I'm working on yes the IP
that I get to play with is someone
else's IP correct not mine so I find
myself in this process very amenable to
change and open ideas because I didn't
create this stuff I'm just remix in
these materials the way I described it
to the people today I was like I'm not
really doing anything except like
putting together a puzzle like you gave
me a box and I know what the picture
eventually has to look like I just have
to [ __ ] put it together and stuff but
like the pieces are all yours without
your material none of the ideas that I'm
bringing to it could exist cuz
all of the ideas I have are predicated
on the IP the intellectual property your
case I know this for a fact is
completely original whole cloth created
by you and yours are just you just me
and myself and I you yourself and you
when you're given notes like now I'm
given notes I'm like oh my god I got a
buck against it all I'm like [ __ ] I'll
make that work or that can and sometimes
you're like oh [ __ ] that's even [ __ ]
better but what that again that it's
easy for me because I'm like well none
of this shit's mom playing with house
money what is it like when it's your
thing and they're like we want you to do
this and you're like well that's not
what I want to do at all I think for me
it's it's always a matter of circling my
wagons it's it is what Peggy Carter used
to say about compromise like compromise
where you can and when you can't dig in
your heels you know and say no more no
further it's what is this thing supposed
to be to be fair so that J michael
Straczynski doesn't pull his hair out
Captain America said it first in the
comics that line that they appropriated
for Peggy in the movie but just you know
I will rip off a piece of my key card
there you go just a little touch but
it's it's remembering why we all fell in
love with this thing why the people who
wanted to buy it wanted to buy it why I
wanted to ride it why and hopefully if
that thing is the same thing and then
circling the wagons around that and
everything else is negotiable to a
certain degree well like that all right
we can talk about this why don't you
like this I can find another workaround
but if you don't like what it is then we
have a fundamental difference of opinion
upon which there can be no further
conversation unless you on this same
page unless we both want to make the
same thing then then I don't see how we
can keep going hopefully this isn't too
irritating for folks hopefully there's
useful information without knowing what
the pieces are at play but you know it
is it's it's an interesting insight like
I guess you do have to go like look
these are the core principles of the
thing and everything else is malleable
but for negotiation but like it if these
five things are these five things [ __ ]
it there's no point in doing it totally
like if it's Robin Hood there's got to
be a Sherwood Forest there's got to be a
bow and an arrow and there's probably
got to be
Sheriff of Nottingham otherwise you can
sit in the future if you want it could
be a black dude or a lady it could be
then there better be a Maid Marian or
it's gay porn the whole [ __ ] way you
gotta throw a lady in there somewhere
man that's on effects next summer Ryan
Murphy's Robin Hood so wait there are
certain immutable things that you can't
change but beyond that like if it makes
it better let's do it if it doesn't then
I'll try and talk you out of it but I'm
I'm an inherently collaborative person I
guess why do TV TV is not a B hey you're
good in a writers room and just I mean
right here on the show whenever we talk
you were able to like take an idea
expound upon it and find a better idea
and stuff but it's also like you know I
wouldn't want to do this by myself
because it's nice having another person
to talk to and spin all ideas off of and
incorporate and adjust and make one
voltron of ideas and if you're not going
to do that then you know we'll just be
one sad lion by yourself and they'll
somebody was like I understood that all
right well let's we got so much to
[ __ ] do and so much to get into let's
dive in it but before we go geek should
we address like hugging top stories a
day yeah man
holy [ __ ] it has really very little to
do with our world except I you know I I
was whole hog on this show and even
talked about it on this show how much I
dug it
I flew in from Vegas this morning and I
had this meeting in the afternoon about
this thing I'm working on
so I about two hours where I'm like I'm
gonna grab a nap and I laid down in the
bed and then my wife Jennifer wakes me
up she goes get up it's time for your
meeting and Roseanne's been canceled
and so I'm still waking up in like one
of these things isn't true what are you
talking about and she go they'd she said
she put a racist tweet on Twitter and
and ABC cancelled the show yeah and
instantly I started chuckling because
I'm like Oh silly woman that would never
happen no corporation would ever act
that fast this isn't like she says crazy
things all the time in place we live in
a country where the president says worse
things all the time there will be no
punishment for this and [ __ ] sure
enough ABC was just like now there is
the show's [ __ ] canceled yeah for a
minute for at least the last year
Nightline blame but like it feels like
for at least last year or more somebody
erased the [ __ ] lines and there were
no lines anymore and you could just say
the most [ __ ] horrible [ __ ] and get
away with it and suddenly it was like
can you feel a brand-new day like like
there was somebody did something right
now you know you read online there's a
bunch of people going oh they only did
it because of this and this and [ __ ]
the show one of the reasons that what
are the well it's one of those like yes
she she tweeted an awful horrible thing
ABC is run by a black woman maybe don't
make racist jokes to the president of
your [ __ ] network to your boss in
public not a good look but not a good
look and also she met her boss it's not
like they just hired a new boss or
something right
chanting Dungey said that Channing
Tatum's brother no black woman they have
the same first name it must be brother
that's how that goes they're clones but
but ABC does not own Roseanne and
ownership is a big deal
curse you Warner carci Warner owns
Roseanne so like ages of shield will
stay on ABC for as long as it has to
because ABC owns that show so what
you're saying is the ages of shield
people can say all the racist things
they lock
agent coulson can really just put it all
out there and [ __ ] and they're like we
own the show sorry folks no but I get
what you saying so that could be a if
they don't the show and then there's no
point in going down this road but if
they had owned the show would they have
acted as fast but point is it becomes a
different conversation when there's real
financial stakes involved right they
make ad revenue but they don't make any
revenue off of syndication over
international sales over any of that
stuff that makes TV actually go so they
make money just not all the money not
all the money and some people online are
suggesting well maybe that was a factor
in their decision or something you know
the it premiered huge like through the
roof for broadcast TV came and dropped
off precipitously over the course of the
first season to the point where it's a
hit but it's not a phenomenon at the end
of it yes and no it is they're saying I
read an article today going it is the
number three show of the year thus far
so you got [ __ ] football this is us
and like Roseanne so as you know even if
they dropped in ratings they were still
- juggernaut like that's why I was
[ __ ] stunned that they cancelled it
cuz I'm like don't they got 20 million
people watching that show like I've
they've worked around scandals before in
the past and it just felt like somebody
somewhere it was just like enough like
we may lose a buck or two but it's like
[ __ ] not work and like Roseanne has
always been this person but she's
managed to for the most part be this
person in private yeah and it's you
can't be this person in public because
Hollywood will wash a bunch of [ __ ]
under the rug
we spent 20 years and Harvey Weinstein
villain didn't know it because Hollywood
was not motivated in any way to change
that action right but when you start to
queeth you rakes this [ __ ] out
and you're owned by ABC which is owned
by Disney which has to sell a lot of
[ __ ] to families of all colors which is
and just had an amazing year just had
[ __ ] Black Panther make 750 million
dollars domestically bringing a bunch of
black people into the Disney fold that
might not have been before and suddenly
Roseanne starts calling people monkeys
yeah
like they're bringing people in the door
and that's your Walmart leader oh your
fountain is over here sweetheart
[ __ ] man yeah so like it's it's you're
right it probably is a decision that
would happen I've never seen it happen
as fast it's crazy how fast it happens
and and just shows you like how the bar
is so [ __ ] low that I was like oh you
must be wrong there's no way that they
would ever act that faster and they
[ __ ] did and I don't know I wonder if
that's the is that the beginning of
something do you think I don't know
or is it an outlier moment is like how
it happened to her in that show and
that's that I mean I think that if you
know Jeffrey Tambor had been revealed to
be as brutally awful on Arrested
Development as he was on transparent I
forgot about that [ __ ] story and that
was only a few days ago Jason Bateman is
like thank you yeah Jason Bateman's like
who [ __ ] said what now
Roseanne I'm off the hook yeah so they
took a bunch of heat as well man yeah
because you know they had this
roundtable for the New York Times and
they're all sitting there and Jessica
Walters is talking about the abuse she
took at the mouth I suppose of Jeffrey
temple just yeah verbally abusive
verbally abusive and just kind of awful
and mean-spirited same reasons he got
fired off with transparent was the thing
he'd been doing to her specifically for
four or five years of that show is that
right
yeah the only version of the story I got
was they they want like this was a
one-time outburst I you know I don't
think anybody is a one-time outburst
person if especially if you got fire the
last time for being the one time
outburst guy agreed so and she's sitting
there in this interview crying at having
to recount this memory and Jason Bateman
is like but my French every Tambor is a
lovely person how could he possibly do
anything wrong as a dude there's a woman
crying right next to you about what he
did to her and you're concerned about
how your other friend the dude feels
about having been told that he might
have been a bad person man it's like
that it's not a good look and of course
it was he gave me apologize apologize
that I you know after going on Twitter
and seeing the reaction of people I
realize I made a bad move dude
it kind of got Kent turn to Twitter for
attitude adjustments when you're sitting
next to this lady who's crying yeah that
would be the that's the weird part of
the whole thing is like no matter how
you feel on the subject if somebody's if
somebody's that emotionally wrought over
it and you're still trying to mansplain
how like well is Hollywood and that's
what our family yeah and also I for the
record like look I don't work
I never made some of this cool those
[ __ ] Arrested Development but I've
been working and bottom-feeding in this
business for quite some time and I don't
think you don't I've never you don't
need shitty people to make [ __ ] good
stuff like I've never been a person
that's like well that they they're
horrible to everybody but will tolerate
that because we're getting great [ __ ]
stuff out of that I mean I hang out with
people that people don't [ __ ] like
like Jason Mewes but like not yeah we've
never been successful so he's not
helping clearly but but like III just
don't agree with that like there was a
point made about like well sometimes
making this stuff you deal with
different personalities and stuff like I
had one experience working on a set with
a guy I had to work with whose
personality was way different and it was
it just made me want to leave the
[ __ ] business because it's like it's
supposed to be fun like you know if you
get to be like in an entertainment for a
living it's like when in the [ __ ]
lottery cuz you get to make pretend for
a living like so there should never be
an issue she just [ __ ] count your
blessings keep your mouth shut and not
make life miserable for other people or
your [ __ ] self and stuff it's been a
bad week for TV I had [ __ ] week for
TV good week couple of weeks for movies
though ah excellent segue into that into
the heart of our show
pull that [ __ ] right off the segue well
done so butter smooth that did not need
attention to called it and yet we did
good as the true sometimes you know
credit where credit's due
all right the show is starting in
earnest now ladies and gentlemen and we
will start by speaking about two
gigantic movies in the Nerdist fear of
the geekiest fear or whatever that came
and
went kinda while the taught while we
were away and we haven't gotten a chance
to talk about them where do you want to
start first alright noted that's not
enthusiastic alright if we have to which
kind of seems like based on the box
office what America said just so low
like do you want ticket to solo like
alright and then some did not say that
could I get Deadpool to again no okay I
saw it and I enjoyed it I saw it when I
was where I saw it here I guess early
screening or New York here I saw
Avengers in the mirror I enjoyed it I
thought it was fun I wrote on Twitter
but I thought it was fun fanservice man
I thought like there were great moments
like I would not have written the hand
meat chewy seen the way they did and not
because I'm like my version was better
I'm not that clever I thought that was a
very clever way to [ __ ] do it and
stuff I liked every everything that
referenced are tied into the [ __ ]
other movies at one point they've
referenced Bossk and I was like wow I
have that figure still like and of
course when you know the guy who's Darth
Maul spoilers yeah come on we're in a
Star Wars [ __ ] bar that's true I'm
sorry it's a space Cantina yeah hey hey
not at all unlicensed thing never mind
it's just not actionable
it's an astro brewery yes yes Darth Maul
I had to sit there and do them first I
was doing backwards mental math because
I was going wait a second clearly
they're not referring to the cartoons
because no movies would ever do that so
so I was like this must be a mistake
because I'm in my head I'm like when
they found Darth Maul was in Phantom
Menace and [ __ ] Anakin Skywalker was
just a little boy there are they saying
that [ __ ] Han Solo was older than
Anakin I was trying to do all this
mental math and then I read afterwards
like no man we're [ __ ] cop into the
fact that like in the cartoons he's been
back for a while so much so that the guy
who voices Darth Maul in the cartoons
was the guy who voiced him in the movie
they didn't use Peter Serafinowicz they
used the guy who does the what who's
been doing him and rebels and Clone Wars
I guess prior to that so you know that
to me was like good for them like why
not accept extended universe and and the
animated shows that they've done because
they've built the Star Wars universe and
like they're - a lot of people those
stories are just as important as [ __ ]
Luke and Leia and Han and stuff that
being said you know it it didn't play
like a saga movie didn't have to because
it's kind of telling us standalone story
rogue one gets the edge and a big bad
way because no matter what happens in
rogue one like honestly it's a tough
curve to judge by because all you
remember of rogue one is the [ __ ]
last minute with Darth Vader and you're
like oh my god I would I would [ __ ]
let my mother be handed over to
cannibals so I could watch that one more
time you know
it's a move it's a one minute of filmdom
that makes like the previous two hours
doesn't matter if it was good or bad
it's like [ __ ] there you go man that's
well done and solo was fun but it never
had that scene that one scene where
you're like that's why this [ __ ]
exists and I'm certainly not saying it
has no reason to exist
it's a [ __ ] movie it's absolute
[ __ ] it's it's fun some people like
you know treat the [ __ ] more seriously
like religion and feel like the movie is
an affront to everything that is Star
Wars is something I you know I still
watch his movies and to me it was
entertaining they got me a few times I
didn't I didn't cry and that seemed to I
mean for you yeah no I was I put up my
tweet and somebody like [ __ ] it
immediately afterwards a bunch of people
were like I don't see anything about
crying I guess that's my that's my two
thumbs up like you know I cried like a
[ __ ] all throughout this and then to be
fair I didn't like there were moments
like that was like that's awesome and I
was calling out and stuff but I'd never
like reached that teary point or
something like that so I enjoyed it
quite a bit I couldn't understand the
box office being what it was which you
know it's not dismal in the toilet but
it's it's the lowest Star Wars opening
or JC said since Return of the Jedi and
only because that's 1983 numbers when
people were paying a buck 50 for a movie
and there was only like a thousand
screens in the country yeah and not
because people are like we're tired of
this Star Wars and [ __ ] it was more just
about like that's the last time Star
Wars made this little money was when
Star Wars couldn't make any more money
because it was the 80s or something like
that so some people are you know have
written the pieces now if I guess Star
Wars dead is this Star Wars fatigue and
[ __ ] like that I I don't know I think
this poor little movie was you know
hamstrung from the moment they they
[ __ ] went toward production because
you're casting a young Harrison Ford I
thought that kid did a great job Alden
Ehrenreich he did a great job but
there's the weird thing of we know
exactly what young Harrison Ford look
like yeah
also we know what he looked like as han
Solo
so it's like I don't what yeah sure did
he grow another foot over the next few
years yeah that was waiting for that
line in the movie aren't you a little
short for a solo but I thought like you
know in the when they cast it there were
a bunch of people in the beginning or
why would you [ __ ] do this and then
they cast and they're like he ain't
[ __ ] Harris before that part of it
worked out like that was not problematic
by any stretch of the imagination
there's nothing in it problematic but
there's also nothing in it that you know
there's no Darth Vader shows up in the
end of rogue one moment there's no I
mean I don't think this is the moment
that everyone points to and last Jedi
but I will wear you know [ __ ] they I
big jump take the jump to light speed
through the Imperial ship [ __ ] like that
we like this just felt like it was done
correctly the whole time I was watching
the movie I was like yeah that makes
sense yes they did that oh my god the
Kessel run like they they were ticking
boxes and I thought they took their
boxes very well but this is a movie that
started life as a different movie and
then became the movie that it is now I
don't feel there's necessarily proof of
that like as I watched the movie I
wasn't sitting there going well that's
the old plot line and this is the new
plot line but it was already fraught
with complication getting to the screen
in the first place so I don't know if
that was a factor I've read some folks
online do a lot of last Jedi blaming
which I thought was kind of interesting
they feel burned by last Jedi and some
people are just like my name's Paul and
this between y'all and I've stepped off
of Star Wars and maybe that's why it
didn't open it which is weird because if
you if your problem was the last Jedi
which was diverging too greatly from
what you thought the saga should be yes
solos like the [ __ ] warm blanket of
nostalgia of a look it's Han Solo it's
chewy it's like as the Falcon is land
notes all the things you loved as a kid
we're giving it to you man in a bottle
just suck it up and it's true like that
milk that comes out of the [ __ ]
no we're never talking about the man
last Jedi titty milk that Luke drank
some sort of sea ostrich what did you
think of the flirt it's funny I was
watching over the weekend the paramon
Network had a massive Indiana Jones
marathon because they have it so they
did it and I was watching The Last
Crusade which I liked quite a bit I mean
some people feel a little treacly an
emotional but whatever and the first 15
minutes of that movie yeah are hey did
you want to know how Indy got the scar
on his chin and Wayne first use a whip
and how he gets afraid of snakes yeah
that's yeah like this belongs in a
museum all of the things you love the
mini in 15 minutes I'm like you know
that's about the amount of time that I
need for them to tell this story and
then the rest of it is new story look
I've never like too much of this was
like you said checking boxes too much of
it felt like and not even the best
version of that like Han Solo gets his
name from some Rando character that
we've never seen before and will never
see again and that's how Solo gets solo
that was honestly like you know I'll go
with you on that that was the one moment
movie where I was like oh oh you're
doing this alright well moving on is
Chewie here yet like the Kessel run
never seemed to be at all about speed
yeah this is come on you ruined in the
movie for me now making me think about
it the most boring version of the castle
I was gonna drive through the soup for a
while and look it's gonna be like the
asteroid scene an empire but not as cool
it's fine it was now that I think about
it was kind of like you know the Kessel
run maybe because we didn't know what it
was it was just a bunch of words you
know when it when we were kids like all
that sounds [ __ ] badass but I think
and you you know look and then world of
infinite possibility there could have
been a different version of the Kessel
run that didn't involve like we got to
keep this [ __ ] cool or it's gonna blow
up that's why we're going fast in my
version when I was a kid it was a
[ __ ] race it was just thinking I was
Han Solo he's got two shoots people for
no [ __ ] reason and then gives a guy a
quarter
like so to me it was just like some
[ __ ] crazy race or something like
that not like oh it had a practical
real-world application that then would
also help birth the rebellion yeah I
mean it's it's an aggressively competent
movie you know like it's God I what a
weird and so so much so that you can
hear it and be like thank you and then
be like wait a second aggressively
competent like it's not doing anything
special but it's doing it pretty good
yeah they're all very good at their jobs
yeah that's the thing
every player involved there's nobody did
Point C to be like they [ __ ] ruin
this because there's nothing ruined it's
totally entertaining as far as I'm
concerned but that being said the parts
seem bring it in the song yeah like they
seem to be like every element is kind of
great and the story itself is just fine
yeah but like it seems like everyone's
super game there's real Charm City with
the cast and stuff yeah and yeah I will
say that watching watching this movie
that the the biggest problem I had with
this movie okay is what it does to a new
hope for me well because a new hope the
story of Han Solo when a new hope is man
out for himself
scoundrel smuggler criminal he's only
doing it for the money he you know
there's the moment just before the Death
Star run where he takes his money and
goes and you as a viewer the first time
you see that you're like yeah he's that
guy of course is gonna do that he's
greedy he wants the money he's got debts
to pay off he's gonna price of his head
he's gone and then he shows up and then
he's the [ __ ] hero and that surprise
only works if you don't think he's gonna
do that oh I see what you're saying so
the idea is right you see that you look
holy [ __ ] he's [ __ ] there the Falcon
is here and he saves Luca let's blow
this thing go home like this is amazing
because you've never seen a movie in
your entire life
oh my god he came back
I've never saw it coming it was the
first movie that I ever saw like that's
what that did for me what else he's
[ __ ] back now if you know it's like
40 years later like he's [ __ ] back
but if you watch those movies in order
now if you said a kid down and solos you
know not quite the first one you're
gonna watch yeah that's in there you now
fully expect that dude to show up
because we're told in this movie he's a
good guy we're literally told you're a
good guy what does he do he doesn't take
the coaxial cables [ __ ] whatever he
he'll it was like I could keep it for
myself and make money but now let's
start a rebellion I guess maybe cuz
that's a good idea
for me the smuggler who's I mean at
least he shoots first this one that's
not bad yes but like this story we're
being told is that he's a hero who kind
of doesn't want to be but totally is
right and so now if you get to a new
hope you expect him to do that because
that's all we've been told he's gonna do
like why would you like of all the
blacks you could fill in in this story
why would you do that
of all of the things you could affect
going forward like rogue one works for
me really well because it doesn't in any
it heightens the things you knew before
but doesn't affect the things you knew
before but it slots in perfectly it's
not [ __ ] with your memories of the
other stuff it's just oh [ __ ] that's
Vader that's amazing this is like but
I'm now there's emotional contours that
I didn't have before that don't help you
texted me after you so we were going
back and forth and you brought up
something about Khaleesi what is her
name in this movie Oh Kira Kira I which
I hadn't thought about tell them you're
cute I don't remember what did I text
you [ __ ] really throw away [ __ ] just
crap out good ideas so lady you don't
remember your point was you you know
where it's going alright you you were
going off on this tear about [ __ ]
like you know it ruins stars because
they make him a good guy now you expect
this kind of [ __ ] from but you said and
you can see where it's going like if
they make a sequel is before it open who
know I doesn't look like that's likely
at this point but maybe you know doesn't
mean they could stay you know they could
double down and be like [ __ ] you
we're doing it again solo again [ __ ]
solo again naturally so mark was saying
that based on the ending with what is
her name curious yeah yeah how you know
that reveals that she's working with
crimson dawn and stuff like that
that you said if they did a solo to she
would be killed and that's what made him
detention that's what hardens him which
I was like when you said it and then
after I thought about for three seconds
I was like oh my god he's absolutely
right like that's the only way that
story could go because we never heard
her about her again and that's also what
softens him towards tiny brunettes with
British accents but yeah like I did not
mind the movie at all but it never it
never argued for its existence in a way
that that wrote one argues for his
existence I think again I don't think
anybody like I don't think he pointed
people and be like oh that's why or this
is why or this person failed in some way
but I think somebody is a Ron Howard
deserves some sort of honorable mention
they're like a B as a tough ball to pick
up pick up a movie that like they're
taken away from other filmmakers and he
seemed game the entire time say what you
will about that movie but he was a very
enthusiastic director who was selling
the product long before it was done like
he was happy to be there and and yes
it's aggressively competent you know I
would go even further and say it's a
well-made flick incredibly well-made as
I watched the movie I never sat there
wants and be like I can do better than
that Ron Howard not once like every step
of the way I was like you beat me I'll
beat your world go you know so I think
he did a wonderful job ask you to
stalemate from the jaws of defeat there
you go
yeah I'll take that and and hopefully
they don't like you know put him in
movie Jail or kick him out of the club
hopefully he gets rewarded for coming in
and helping them out even if it didn't
turn into the movie they hope it is and
or could be and is it like dead it's not
a disaster right
103 million dollars over the four-day
weekend which is still like 50 million
shy of rogue one which is still 100
million shy of force awakens right it's
doing okay internationally but not
amazing it's it's now at let me see
172 worldwide so it only made 72 million
dollars worldwide
internationally overseas which did it
open in like China but in China they
don't care
China doesn't care that much about Star
Wars really yeah
it opened number three in China
yeah beaten by other things that aren't
Star Wars which shouldn't be possible
that's how they sold the tickets other
things that aren't Star Wars I'll take
two but I think that Star Wars the the
engine of Star Wars for a very long time
it's been established it's always been
here's the thing that I've loved since I
was a kid and I only get it every so
often you know like it's in a theater
and you'd see the Lucasfilm logo come up
and you see a long time ago two guys for
them oh my god so much so that like we
were excited to see Phantom Menace yeah
because we saw that and we were like
it's gonna be just like we were kids
minutes into it we're like oh go back to
that card just all I need is the a long
time ago part yeah but I've never I
never thought that I would see those
words it's a long time ago yes it's just
like regularity like we're just we're
getting it all the time we're getting
these movies every six months from now
that's an interesting point that I
haven't thought of you're right man it
is a nostalgia engine you can't be
nostalgic for something with like here
you go well here like number one I don't
look let's let's do this two-parter is
it a problem and going forward how would
one even correct it like you can't shut
the Star Wars machine off at this point
they have too much money invested in it
they're opening a [ __ ] theme park
that is always and again we shouldn't
like hopefully this isn't misconstrued
as a conversation where it's like Star
Wars is dead what next like you know
they didn't have as great an opening as
they were hoping for still made a
[ __ ] hundred million
it feels like they need to not that
everybody still from Marvel but Marvel
will give you [ __ ] Avengers it will
cost you 250 million dollars and then
they will give you ant-man which costs
them 80 million dollars like they wrote
they will sort of play both of those
levels and like we're gonna memorize our
exposure with this one and spend through
the roof on that one so if they spent
three hundred million dollars on solo
what three hundred million dollars
before I mean the movie looks expensive
what expensive but it didn't need to oh
but it's three hundred because that's
not all for that movie that includes the
previous yeah because they shot an
entire movie with Miller and Laura
directing and candidate and then shot
another movie with Ron Howard and that's
the one we saw right but you can't spend
that much money on a movie like this
like guard your [ __ ] wallet a little
bit do you think we ever ever see any of
the Miller Lord Boot version like I know
they'll never release it as a movie but
just footage you ever get out you know I
mean the one that I want to see the most
is Michael K Williams Omar from the wire
he was in anyways he was supposed he was
cast as driving boss he was the one I
call bet me that was his role he was the
the leader of the crimson dawn whatever
the [ __ ] he was that guy and because he
couldn't show back up for reshoots they
had to completely redo that entire role
with paul bettany the pub bat needs to
felt like we're just gonna be into this
room one set we can do this in like
three days did have the feeling of like
they got through that pretty quick yeah
but Omar is that [ __ ] guy I'd watch
that all day we're never gonna sit nope
it is not the end of Star Wars by any
stretch of the imagination is it no no
there no what's next next is episode 9
is the next one we see and then they are
doing it Boba Fett movie which they just
announced that got lost in the news a
little bit
the day they announced I saw some people
like grousing where I'm like what are
you kidding me james mangold the great
director of [ __ ] Logan one of the
greatest comic movies ever made not to
mention just a fantastic film is rumored
to be handling the Boba Fett movie yes
so if Logan interested you in the least
and if you like good storytelling it
should interest you that's that's
promising
to say that like we're gonna give the
character that nobody really knows that
much about other than like [ __ ] he looks
cool he died like a puma guy who
literally [ __ ] took one of the most
beloved characters in the world and
spoilers killed him and we still gave
him praise still like you're a genius
man like it's like the [ __ ] kid came
over your house he took your toys broke
them on your like good job because it
was just so brilliantly done and stuff
so if you're gonna give that guy Boba
Fett you've got look I'm in the bag for
a Boba Fett movie regardless but hand it
to that guy
[ __ ] man we're going in knowing we're
gonna get piece of quality entertainment
he's a great filmmaker man I love do you
remember Jefferson's remake of 410 it
was 310 - yeah it's great it's a really
[ __ ] great and I'm not every western
guy's really great yeah I mean they're
not gonna fire him I mean they might
fire fire who James Mangold I mean Cathy
fires people oh yes yeah that has
happened but do you think it happens
that much anymore like I bet you going
forward they don't get rid of people
because it's now happened too many times
enough to make a joke where somebody can
really like Cathy comrade as [ __ ]
fired more people than well she won't
fire that many more because Hollywood is
running out of him right in a joke hold
on okay I was going to come on top of
you but good no no I wish you'd kept
going because people saw backstage as I
literally had to look up to figure out
what many months line we don't even know
if he has the job like it's just a rumor
we heard but like it's nice that you're
confirming he will not be fired not be
fired
they're running out of white dudes with
beards to hire to direct Star Wars
movies they got one right here man I'll
shave it I got it yeah that's that
sounds fantastic I I'm in I'm in for
that my favorite pitch that I heard
online the guy named the art of coop was
his twitter handle was like I'm down for
this movie if it's some kind of no
nothing idiot finds the armor outside
the Sarlacc pit and then puts it on and
pretends to be Boba Fett and like what
happens when the world fears you was the
most dreaded bounty hunter would you
just a [ __ ] guy I have be honest with
you I don't want that version at all I
will take the coop haven't ideas and
[ __ ] but that's not the version of Boba
Fett I want to see because we got the
[ __ ] origin story we know how we we
all saw Attack of the Clones
oh he's the son of Jango yeah yeah but
what else don't you know about him
that's the thing here's how he got his
rocket pack you because maybe that's the
whole movies about movies about how the
rocket wouldn't come out of his back and
[ __ ] and ultimately they figure out why
at the end and the third act is because
it might hurt children deep deep cuts
all right
so solo I'm thumbs up I don't want
somebody like somebody took my tweet a
bunch of people they're like well that's
not a [ __ ] rave like he must hate it
and [ __ ] like they thought I was code
code messaging or whatever the [ __ ] go
on like yeah I liked it a lot I did
enjoy it a lot
so if I had to Ebert and Roeper it or
Siskel and Ebert it I would definitely
be thumbs up what would you be
I'm not quite they did not have a middle
mark they they had up and down they did
not bug and have they weren't thumbing
people they were so which is I've heard
tell about that row poor fella what is
it it's not a crime but what did movies
become this hard that we can't just be
like we like it it's good there's a lot
of like well uh pish you know and stuff
like that let's jump to that man
Deadpool happened Deadpool to happen
while we were gone and it's it's weird I
mean I guess like it can't be surprising
because we've seen the first bone stuff
but it's it's it's not like making as
much noise as I would imagine it would
have especially with how much we all
seem to love the first one I dug it but
the first 15 minutes I'll be honest with
you I was like oh like it didn't feel
like the movie I was hoping it would be
and not but like I had a different movie
in my head just didn't feel like the
last movie and then about like once the
cable [ __ ] kicked in suddenly the rest
of it kicked in but one I'm you know I'm
[ __ ] loved the entire concept and I
loved the entire execution of Deadpool
but my favorite element of Deadpool was
his relationship with Vanessa yeah so in
this movie when they fridge her in the
first 10 minutes yeah I was like alright
well hopefully that changes midway
through I know we're playing with time
here and then it never did so the fact
that they had me as much as they did
even though the movie I came to see
wasn't happening like I was looking for
more him and era I liked their
relationship and stuff I thought they
did a good job I thought it was funny
like I thought he made some really great
[ __ ] jokes in in terms of pop-culture
references like I've been to [ __ ] me
and in terms of action sequences of
well done across the boards I really
enjoyed it but it did not stay with me
like Deadpool did and I think that's
because of the relationship between Wade
and Vanessa and Deadpool that like I
don't know it was insanely [ __ ]
touching that's the relationship you
want like maybe not you know getting
pegged
although looked interesting but the
especially on the right holiday but the
but yeah I don't know like that to me in
a in a story that was a you know of
beyond the reasonability just [ __ ]
outlandish as [ __ ] even for a superhero
story that grounded human element of
misfits finding each other the one
person who can look past what you look
like in the case of Wade Wilson
you know [ __ ] hell
and fine love that what that's what
resonated with me I know that if you ask
most people they would not be like Oh
Deadpool I love it for the love you know
they you're going to Deadpool for the
joke so Deadpool too delivered all
big-time on the jokes and stuff the
cable stuff was great was just watching
x-force come to life it's really cool
and what they did with him as well come
to life and come to death very quickly
but but I missed that aspect it felt
like she was in movie Jail and she
literally was and for most of the scenes
like you know she's just trapped in
another place but that being said I'd
totally [ __ ] dug it definitely thumbs
up but I didn't enjoy it as much as I
enjoyed Deadpool for for that reason
because I really thought about okay how
come I'm not thinking about it as much
and stuff and I think it had everything
to do with that yeah but and certainly
not like don't go [ __ ] say it
definitely go see it it's fantastic but
for me it didn't connect on the level
the Deadpool did you yeah I mean it it
lost me I think at the same place that
kind of lost you in the beginning which
is I'm never here for the let's kill the
girl to motivate the boy to do things
right like she was a full-on character
in that first movie she had she had
motivations and desires and wants and
she wanted Wade and that's what he was
driving towards and I get all that hmm
and so to remove
that from this movie left me adrift a
little bit right and he never bonded
with the kid which is what they're
trying to replace you with is the idea
that all right well wave is he's got to
absorb this child into his life and
that's gonna let him grow to be a bigger
person and but because he actively hated
the kid until three-quarters way through
the movie you never got that so there
was no emotional center to it without
the emotional center it becomes just
references yes because none of the jokes
are coming from character they're coming
from
look at this thing which is like another
thing that you already know or from
another thing that you already like even
the plot I mean the plot is [ __ ]
Terminator it's I gotta go or looper I
gotta go back in time and kill this kid
is gonna grow up to become you know a
serial killer oh my god you're right
let's do that part you know it only
picks up again for me even like
enjoyment wise when x4 shows up that
stuff is amazing because it's all from
these characters is all from Wade's
desire to put a family together it's all
from I built this unit that I'm going to
shed wilfully through violence and
ridiculousness and it's it's fun to
watch but too much of the movie felt a
bit like you know not quite checking
boxes but just look how smart we are
with references we can get and we have
all of the x-men now spoilers behind a
door and we're never gonna show you them
for just thought that was a cute joke
yeah was it it was so fast I didn't
notice was it the real cast McAvoy and
kelsey grammer and really that's pretty
[ __ ] impressive yeah I mean but I
came out of the movie like you know that
it's not bad I mean they did what they
aim to do and they execute it pretty
well but I laughed more at Ragnarok than
I did at Deadpool - oh alright I know
what you may be right and all of those
jokes are character jokes they're all
from like we've known Thor and Loki for
so long we understand their relationship
and so much of this humor is coming from
them we're not from look at the funny
[ __ ] we're putting in front of them it's
look what they're doing right how
they're relating to each other
look at how they're relating to going
through a devil's anus look at you know
since the sun's getting real Oh buddy
like all of that [ __ ] is stuff they did
that joke in Deadpool as well
the Suns getting real low I mean I'm the
level of just somebody who enjoys
[ __ ] jokes about comic-book movies
and comic books it [ __ ] hands down
easily delivered but there was a bit of
ticking boxes to it and you know of
course it's tough to surprise twice and
you know it's I think what was
surprising about Deadpool was how
[ __ ] brilliant it was like you know
we were hoping to have a good Deadpool
movie we didn't know we'd be given what
we were given it was fantastic and this
felt completely serviceable in terms of
like I was never like oh they [ __ ]
ruined Deadpool my great another entry
I'm all for it but that entry just
didn't grab me in the heart in the
fields as the kids said like the first
one did yeah made all the money right
all the money it's now at four hundred
ninety seven million dollars worldwide
my god it still did like 50 million this
past weekend and weekend - like it's
fine they'll keep making these things
they're gonna make x-force because of
course they're gonna make x-force with
Drew Goddard writing and directing
x-force which is [ __ ] awesome if you
know that you got her luxury Goddard is
the guy who did the Martian at the
Martian and he did daredevil season 1
and cabin in the woods cabin in the
woods that's it he's a Josh he's a Josh
guy and a Jade now he's his own guy
really very much his own good so wait
he's doing mm-hmm Wow I didn't hear that
what is it exactly x-force so wait the
one that we saw in the movie yeah yeah
the exact same one well those characters
those guys well not all of them well
most of them came back well they're
never gonna get Brad Pitt so it's
awesome that was really cool as that was
a neat been neat bit man I enjoyed that
[ __ ] yeah I forgot now I'm making me
want to see it again
I'm sure there's a midnight show
somewhere all right man so that's our
hot takes on those flicks I'm thumbs
thumbs up on it for sure yeah yes should
we dive into the news yeah we have one
wish if I watch something else
I watched something recently or as like
[ __ ] I want to talk about well go on
I'll figure it out later
all right let's dive into the news mark
[ __ ] worked his ass off to curate
this news for you by going to Google so
[ __ ] young for the Internet that's
marks very own Kessel run what what's
going on in the news
so Todd McFarlane who created spawn a
thousand years ago and was one of the
family fathers an image and that was the
launch title that he put out into the
world there was a movie one time with
Michael Jai White and John Leguizamo and
the clown indeed there was a TV show on
HBO of ahead of its time animated series
back in the day adult animation Island a
cell and mister now he's making a movie
version again with blum house with bloom
house which he's been talking about
since like comic-con like I think that's
when he announced that it was him in bum
house teaming up but she's a great
[ __ ] idea yeah I'm writing it and
he's directing it and they just got
Jamie Foxx to star in it Wow yeah that's
[ __ ] huge that's nice it's a big name
for for that movie especially because
they're doing a kind of lower budget
version of that movie Todd wants to do
it down and dirty like he wants to make
it more like The Exorcist or a horror
movie is like Todd's favorite movie is
the onion field so that tells you yeah
you know what I'm saying like the [ __ ]
is that that's a movie from the 70s from
the late seventies early eighties you
don't remember that no it's the onion
yeah look it up it's it's a it's like a
movie that my dad loved oh like about
the intrigue well he didn't my dad
didn't understand the Wicker Man nobody
did
least of all Nicolas Cage what a relief
but but yes wait what were we talking
about in fields yes Todd McFarlane's
favorite movies the under oath of The
Killing Fields no it's a movie it's a
movie about it's Russia we'll talk about
after the [ __ ] show mark just since
all my point is like it's the least
likely movie for a guy who is a visual
artist like it's not like oh it's a
spellbinding look at it's a really quiet
drab like dialogue-driven mystery does
that have layers yes
a field of them mark so I will expect
he's not making the version of spawn
that we saw in the 90s in the movies
with the first CG cape if I remember
correctly his spawn as he describes it
is going to be much more like The
Exorcist or something like that yeah
there's still help involved yes this is
my hell but it's gonna be low-budget
hell and him catching Jamie Foxx is
[ __ ] huge Oscar winner Jamie Foxx
yeah oh my god they could put that on
the spawn Oscar winner Jamie Foxx I used
nur winter todd mcfarlane that's true
that's uh excellent for Todd good friend
that's great news he's directing that
movie too and he's very excited about it
because this is his own character he
created this character and so he worked
on the movie but he can get to direct
the movie so this is big for him to be
able to do that but that's a huge score
cast wise good friend toad luck did you
ever read the Locke & Key comics that's
by Stephen King's kid Joe Hill Joe Hill
I didn't but I'm familiar with them they
have been trying to make a TV show of
lock and key for almost a decade what is
the premise of it
the premise is there's a like The Onion
field it is writers
is it is like the key chamber where
there's nevermind we making a star
chamber if I was making a star chamber
reference wow I didn't have hat head I
would take my hat off that is such a
[ __ ] deep cuts reference but yeah
there's there's a house in middle of
nowhere that has doors that open into
parallel universes including other
people's heads and they kill a lot of
children I believe I never had the book
for a guy who's never at the book you
were doing a good job selling it I was
like I'm gonna [ __ ] read that we
should do that yeah but yeah they tried
to make a fox made a pilot about ten
years ago that never went they just made
a pilot Carlton Cuse written by the dude
who co-produced lost with Damon Lindelof
and Joe Hill himself wrote the pilot for
Hulu which they shot but Hulu didn't
pick up and so now they're taking it to
Netflix did Netflix pick it up Netflix
is in aggressive negotiations to pick up
the IP we're gonna do another pilot
they're gonna recast it all and also
they're gonna they're not even like oh
we'll take what you did and it look like
we'll just do again starting over but
even with the same people just we didn't
like that pilot but we like that's how
much money Netflix has they're like oh
you got a pilot great let's just reshoot
it from scratch because we were just
gonna throw this pile of money out so we
were going to burn it yeah for fuel but
well that's good jogging right on did
you hear that Netflix is now valued
higher than Disney really yeah how is
that possible stock price Wow have a
park so true
Wow really yeah that's the thing that's
why Disney wants their app Channel man
in a big bad way keep making that Donuts
they're making a watchman show did you
read I did read about this talked about
this well I you know look I'm all for
Damon I think he's very creative he's
also a fellow Jersey boy and stuff like
that but when I heard about The Watchmen
HBO series I said thank Christ that's
what it always should have been
take every one of those make
single [ __ ] episode and stuff 12
episode series arc alike oh my god this
is gonna be amazing but now what we've
learned is it's they're not doing the
Watchmen they're not doing Alan Moore's
Watchmen Dave Elmore and Dave Gibbons
Watchmen story that we all know they're
doing some sort of remix that takes
place in the universe of the Watchmen
and features the characters but is not
the story that we're familiar with the
point being I guess Damon said something
like look that was written in the 80s
very reagan-era kind of story that
wouldn't fit in we can't make it fit so
we're gonna do something completely
different so when I heard that I was
like okay great but just then please
don't call it Watchmen you know like if
it's if it's not gonna be the Watchmen
like call it anything else caught like
[ __ ] [ __ ] up heroes but you know I'm
not the writer he is he could come up
with a better name but but why called
the Watchmen if you're not gonna do the
Watchmen you know I mean his perspective
is you know according to his giant
statement he put out on Instagram the
original 12 issues are our Old Testament
when the New Testament came along it did
not erase what came before it
creation Garden of Eden Abraham and
Isaac the flood it all happened and so
it will be with Watchmen the comedian
died Dan and Lorie fell in love as Mandy
has saved the world and dr. Manhattan
left it just after blowing or shaq to
pieces in the bitter cold of Antartica
to be clear watchmen is canon so they're
telling what happens after that okay
yeah then don't call it watch that's all
I'm saying like those are adventures of
watching yeah because we all know what
Watchmen is watch my CDs yeah [ __ ]
I'm but hey but I'm of course I'll watch
it I already paid for HBO so they got my
money and I got Bob Johnson what and
they got Don Johnson in it duck Don
Johnson Miami Vice is Don donkey Don
Johnson is in the Watchmen show he's in
the Watchmen show do we know who he's
playing oh we don't yet but Don Johnson
is in it Tim Blake Nelson Regina King
Louis Gossett [ __ ] jr. Wow really has
and oh [ __ ] irony one legend
[ __ ] bring me the head of Jason
Garrick what is the lit what's the
moment what's the break in the song man
when he's just like that I had a dream
when I was young a dream of sweet
illusion a vision of hope and unity one
sweet union and then it gets [ __ ]
like kids but the darkness wrong dream
that's the Lear goes looking for man but
you don't go hide and then you get in
your [ __ ] plane and save your dad
[Music]
we're gonna launch a raid on durka durka
stand just me my circus
what will the sign be Wow
Louis Gossett jr. man [ __ ] a right on
he's an Academy Award winner forever he
really is Don Johnson wasn't a couple of
shots lieutenant to mayonnaise that's a
good movie that worked still and his
performance is fantastic in it officer
and gentlemen yeah really good in that
and he was wonderful in Jaws 3-d because
somebody had as alvin brought us the guy
who runs the park and [ __ ] Calvin
Broadus was his name I think so noop dog
sniffs dad oh maybe I can I think his
name was Cal because I remember one
point he gets on the mic when everyone's
going crazy in the park and he's like
this is Calvin and he's trying to calm
everybody down even though there's a
shark eating people Wow all right so
wait a second
even if you do those names again we
can't assign parts to them because it
sounds like Watchmen is canon but
they're not playing with those
characters anymore I mean Dan and Laurie
could still be characters just we're not
gonna see the watchman's story Rorschach
could absolutely still be a character
well he got killed in the Watchmen so he
can't be a character he could be
narrating his Diaries which did
into the world again fair enough but
isn't that what the Watchmen was all
about narrating his Diaries
theoretically yeah all right look I'm in
man [ __ ] I just can't believe we're
in a world where not only did we have a
Watchmen movie but they're like oh we're
gonna do a watchman TV show that's not
really the Watchmen like what a
brilliant world were in what else you
got
that is all the news that's the last
news that's it my friend ant-man and the
wasp trailer dropped a new teaser which
shows a lot of the same footage that
we've seen but at the same time they
reference something reference it sounds
like they referenced infinity war yeah
there's some sort of like we have to
save the world or something like that
that I thought was like oh [ __ ] are they
referencing are they tying in do we know
where that stands in the timeline like
does it happen after infinity war I
think it happens before happens between
they reference say it again they
reference Civil War yes Civil War this
is why I wasn't there right so wait but
simple we're having for infinity war he
was a Civil War vice versa right so
Civil War and infinity war they're like
hey he's spending time with his kids
yeah he's like on house arrest spend
time with his kid right so what when
does this [ __ ] movie happen the
answer is you don't know either right
same time right it's what it feels like
from this latest trailer that that they
are acknowledging that half the world's
gone
spoilers half the world's gone missing
or something like that so I found that
intriguing and [ __ ] man like how many
months away is that now it's July right
so what are we right now May June we're
almost June so we got like one [ __ ]
month till that happens yeah I guess
we're gonna start seeing more and more
stuff they're showing more footage of
ghosts the character that's coming
through and so the walls
it [ __ ] looks pretty good I'll go
well don't do is any favor
it looks [ __ ] fantastic
when's the next DC movies at Aquaman
yeah November December
so we'll probably start seeing something
for that soon I mean definitely at Comic
Con but I would imagine before that with
the summer movie season ramping up what
does Warner's have is that ocean's 8 is
their big summer things so we'll be
seeing how appropriate to have an
Aquaman trailer on ok totally unite the
7 remember that when we don't and then
they've released the edge of Aquaman and
said unite the seven you were like the 7
what the seven seas the Justice League
and they never said it I'm still [ __ ]
wondering to this day these mopes may be
alright what else so that's it for the
news it alright we're done with the news
kids which means we come to our favorite
part of fat man I'm Batman that's where
we open it up to you
the audience for Q&A and we have do we
have do we have our Deacon is not here
tonight for the show but the Deacon our
good friend who works over at 40x
dropped off a bunch of [ __ ] we got a lot
of stuff to give away today
what else we got we got t-shirts Oh from
solo oh he's so low t-shirts well you
got a stack would you find them in the
garbage
I'm kidding I'm kidding warned
previously one beautiful it's okay so
the idea of the Q&A is this you ask a
question and if we like that question
you win tickets we got two tickets here
to the 40x theater at La Live's if
you've never said yeah five sets of two
tickets if you've never seen a movie in
4dx do it before you leave this world
and [ __ ] it's pretty impressive way to
see a movie if it snows in the movie
[ __ ] it snows in the movie theater and
your seat
all right that's right Bank I believe I
also got one more thing here what do you
got I got I went to that 31 our
fucked-up Marvel Marathon yes at the El
Cap and at the end of it they gave
everybody a poster oh let's see Oh chin
here it's it's Marvel Studios the first
ten years poster with Iron Man more than
a hero and every character represented
very much so that's so this will give
away also
all right man all right well let's do
this we've got five sets of tickets how
many shirts five beautiful so with if
you get the ticket if we like your
question and the question has to apply
to both of us if you a [ __ ] like house J
then you don't win it what's up
moisturise kids yeah you don't win it
has to be a question we can both answer
you win tickets you win a t-shirt
two tickets one t-shirt and the poster
we'll save for the best of the five
questions do you don't want to do number
six [ __ ] no I gotta go home I had a
heart attack three months ago
get me standing in a bar all night it's
gonna be a [ __ ] excuse for every
night yes four years ago that's true my
wife was just like you want to fool
around I got a heart attack three months
ago man
okay we got our five sets of tickets
we've got solo shirts and we've got the
proprietor of this here bar JC give it
up for JC JC the proprietor here the
scum and villainy Cantina where we do
the show all the time this is the home
of fat man on Batman and the home of
just good times in general JC has taken
time off from me and the bar owner to go
into the audience and find people to ask
us questions he's found one this is
gonna be the first question Ike what is
your name young lady
Sheeran give it up for Sharon everything
[Applause]
all right man go ahead hit us Sharon I'm
a huge fan and my question is not at all
good so I just want to know if there's
any updates on moose jaw's and or hit
somebody who just told you not to do
that fair enough loose jaws and what
else and hit somebody hit somebody moose
jaw's we have money for it isn't that
crazy that just happened in the last two
weeks and stuff more when I know and
I'll know very soon and then hit
somebody is I did two episodes of
SModcast where I read two of the scripts
and then based on that somebody heard it
and said ooh can we do that here why
don't you bring it here and we'll do it
here and we'll do it up and stuff so
it's going to become this other thing
and at the same time Jeremy's simpler
who's the storyboard artist on flash and
Supergirl and Game of Thrones some some
episodes of Game of Thrones it has
started doing it as a graphic novel so
so either way you're seeing it and
you're gonna hear it as well and I'm
kind of hoping between those two that
somebody goes oh this could be this
should be a filmed thing and then
eventually wind up as a miniseries
that's - hope thank you you're welcome
but you win nothing give it up for win
information the greatest prize of all
okay JC find us someone else another
victim oh my god cat ears I've been to
two shows else we're not here in this
bar where I saw cat ears in the real
world one was in [ __ ] New Jersey and
then where was the other one and
Nashville is the other one in purple
hair was there oh my god so yeah man so
[ __ ] I wasn't the only one that left
that's why we haven't had the show for
weeks because cat ears was on the road
and so sure well we can't do a show
without her all right where we going hey
what's your name what's up guys my name
is David give it up for David everybody
David sexy boys need their day we got
tickets and t-shirts yeah by the way oh
I have gifts for you you sign my shirt
and I wrote a little note can you grab
can you having my back I do stand-up and
I have shirts that I sell and I wanted
to give you guys two shirts that I saw
like that I think are hilarious oh I
meant to my friend not you who owned the
bar sorry
way to go friend so I got two shirts I
don't know what size you are anymore
Kevin so big these are shirts right here
for you guys it says I heart cut is
cuddling in quote yeah so if you want
I'll lift if you lift up the front of
the shirt right here there's a secret
message right here and then you lift it
up and it says
I mean finger bangin
he's hoping to give this to my daughter
so glad you pointed out the inside of
the shirt there you go honey
I like how you think I'm gonna pull up
my shirt could be a gift for the wife
there you go love that kind of talk
there baby they're available at David
loot dotnet so you like to plug stuff so
I appreciate anyway I want to thank I'll
be the guy who does it every show thanks
you thank you for doing this show I love
doing I'd miss doing it for the last
month and a half so it's nice to be able
to do here I've talked to people who do
QAS and generally I've the responses
they hate doing it it's like their least
favorite thing to do oh really so the
fact that you guys like doing it and on
top of that your feet like it just means
a lot to us that we're able to like have
this I mean I love Q&A the easiest thing
in the world right somebody like
literally set you up they ask you
questions and all you have to do is
answer them and that's it like the
negotiation is over it's fantastic you
get exactly what you what you want and
the only problem is when people ask me
like it's a little Q and then I give a
metric [ __ ] ton of a instead the problem
is I tend to over deliver well I
appreciate that and I just listen to
that
Canadian Q&A where that guy suggested
that you had Braden their people had
brain damage that engine we're just
talking about that before the show the
Prince George fat man I'm Batman that me
and Mark did we of course is an audio
recording but they also shot it on video
so we're able to put it up on the
channel and there's a kid who got up who
I guess at brain damage I didn't know
that he did certainly it wasn't like
like oh my god it's a parent he just
seemed like a fan very sweet kid but
then his dad gets up like two questions
later and his dad's like that was my son
that was asking the question before he
has brain damage so he was the one that
brought up he's like I think the kid
said it was a sad story yeah
and and his dad was like he is
brain-damaged and he's a fan of yours so
there must be some correlation there so
it was fantastic yeah like you know what
I'm saying like Moe as a parent you know
you must be heartbreaking on some level
for him to have to say that but he got
to a wonderful place in a comfy place
with it where he killed the room and
absolutely broke everyone's heart and we
loved that father-to-son even more than
you know when we just liked his kid it
was really really nice so yeah so that
it's QA for me is is easy and fun I
don't know about for you know I kind of
dig it because nobody ever asking
questions as a journalist for 25 years
I've been asking people questions for
longer than I care to remember so to not
have to ask if she's gonna answer this
is awesome because I'm lazy as [ __ ]
but that wasn't your question no it
wasn't but yeah they were bringing up
try with three-year-old so when they
brought that up I was like wow that's a
hard thing and to be able to beat at
that situation where you can laugh about
it
yeah I'm a big fan of if you don't laugh
you don't heal so you got to talk about
very sorry I didn't use like you've been
going through the heart you had a heart
attack obvious I don't if you guys knew
yeah but uh and I've been going through
four years ago I was diagnosed with
cancer
oh [ __ ] and I'm the worst
no well edition so and unfortunately
with Stage four they told me like I
didn't know it was like I didn't know
how many of there were when they told me
I was like Stage four
apparently yeah so thanks like the yeah
it's a bummer but I lost 150 pounds I
don't recommend the diet but I look
[ __ ] awesome now and Mike was a way
off that by anyway we're both going
through [ __ ] anyway so my question was
I'm going to school to be a writer
okay and this is like a logistic
question like it's not exciting at all
but I think about because I know actors
have to be insurable to be able to act
and do be a part of projects do writers
have to be insurable cuz i'm worried
like being sick like I won't be hireable
oh do writers need to be insurable I
don't know about writers but directors
need to be right
we're gonna make something they always
make me go to the to the doctor and grab
your nuts and you're like yeah
and then like you can be in movies and
I'm like I knew there'd be something
like this so that for directing I know
there's you they make you go to the
doctor I don't think I've ever had to be
in any particularly healthy condition to
be a writer I don't think so I don't you
know anything I don't I mean maybe if
you're on a TV show and the duration of
a thing because writers by and large
their work is done by the time the movie
starts like only insuring you for the
duration of the shoot yeah and they're
gonna make sure you survive the shoot
they could care less if a writer
survives the shoot right not they'd be
happier if we didn't every but yeah I
mean maybe going into it somebody might
ask but I don't even know if they
actually could ask well I want to be on
the stet like I want to write like a
late like I want to be on a comedy show
staff I going to write late
monologue jokes and stuff like that so I
was always wondering if that's like yeah
I mean I don't think they could ask you
to disclose if you have an illness or
not therefore I don't think they could
try and show you because of it I think
you just do it till you can't do it
anymore right in which case forever yeah
it's you [ __ ] right yeah also this is
probably impossible and I'm sure every
single person you've ever come across
has asked you I had a bucket list thing
of being able to because I've from one
of the first times I smoked weed was Jay
and Silent Bob strike back I was not a
STONER in high school I was like oh
that's for losers blah blah and then my
friend who was like he was getting his
mic masters and he was like hey man
we're gonna go we're gonna smoke this is
halo too and I was like I like halo
you're not a loser and I smoked this is
awesome they're like we're gonna go
watch Jay and Silent Bob like and I got
high nose like this is even better when
you're high and so anyhoo you probably
have a busy schedule I'm gonna ask just
so I can ask if there's any chance on
earth that I could smoke with you this
evening I know that's probably
impossible in every chubby white guy on
earth has asked you to smoke with you I
was a fellow fat Mexican looking guy who
would want to smoke with you no I'm
skinny [ __ ] which is weird like I'm
wearing a medium and that's weird
so if there's a chance I could smoke
with you at some point this evening just
not your stuff my stuff you know it's
weird you know
I brought my own polite you're not even
asking to hit my we know I have I have
point I drove from Napa for here so I
brought a lot for myself so you can
smoke your stuff and I can smoking right
because you don't know me yeah whatever
is true okay and you don't have to
answer now I can't say no to the cancer
boy that'd be terrible I have a shirt
that says that also available on my
website David alright yes after the show
we can grab a quick hit in the back does
it that'll be that that's the that's
well do you get tickets because that's
your prize you absolutely get tickets
give them now give it up for him he's
winning tickets ladies gentlemen
excellent job man I'll see you after the
show
alright we go on to the next
oh he's here what's your name man muck
evenin gents fine muck sorry I didn't
either Mike muck mark all right name for
the Star Wars bar like I'm sorry that's
my name's mark that's my British accent
give it up for mark everybody mark what
can we do for you I would like to know
if you could see a comment so there is
an act something was [ __ ] up and I was
like it's written all right mark two
syllables because you're British that's
it
posh and Alan Brady yeah if you could
see a comic book movie that was set at
the time of that comic book characters
creation what movie would that be oh
what a great question if we could see a
comic movie that was based at the time
of that character like a like a Batman
in the Second World War or a text is
Iron Man not like that Wonder Woman was
like set in the pier
that it was said okay what would be mine
this is requiring a lot of knowledge
really I think I got one but I go you go
first of all I think I kind of have
always wanted to see a black lightning
set in the 70s mm-hmm
like I feel like disco black lightning
would be kind of [ __ ] phenomenal and
then you also do it where like there's a
blackout in New York and Black Lightning
has to save New York because there's no
more power except for one brother in
Harlem who can light [ __ ] up yeah that I
would kind of watch but uh that that's
that's my page what you got
Jonah hit mine yeah I'd like to see
hopefully when this deal will go through
the Fantastic Four a 60s bass fantastic
400 set in the 60s that's wow man that
is good let me see I don't have that on
my list I mean I would like to right now
that I've heard it I go that's good but
that didn't spring to mind
all right origin story common create
what yeah I've got real answer env going
on between the two of you what is your
second answer Cold War name or Cold War
name or it rhymes
oh yeah that'd be fine all right that
sounds good [ __ ] I still don't have any
hold on what is my favorite era
I like the 70s but mark took that I'm
tempted to say 80s alpha flight but
that'd be the second show in a row where
I've referenced alpha flight and people
will start to realize that I am Canadian
a good time to be Canadian it is a great
time to be community um [ __ ] man I don't
know what I would choose maybe it's cuz
I'm locked into comics that I'm having
this thought but it is about comics I
don't know cuz I can't even say like oh
the nineteen [ __ ] 39 Batman or
something like that because I don't like
Batman with the gun
you know without a rogue's gallery
fighting dudes and suits because that's
kind of like what it was in the
beginning until Bill Finger kind of
brought all the great stuff into it I
don't know I have no [ __ ] answer
you've literally stumped me man [ __ ]
well done well done you get the tickets
excellent job sir take those and take a
shirt as well you don't want to eighties
Constantine no no no I think about not
all I'm shot up it's going to be working
like you know a [ __ ] program on the
background on my phone for the rest of
the episode where I'm going or what what
is it is it Hong Kong Phooey
okay hey man what's your name going on
guys I'm Adam hey Adam Abel give it a
Bradham excellent shirt Adam very
appropriate for where we are what it
felt appropriate this is I'm gonna
[ __ ] beer two minutes yeah that's a
well-kept beer look at it yeah I try you
know you know the very first beard I
ever grew my dad said who are you trying
to be Kevin Smith you know you should I
just turned around and told them no dad
this is my [ __ ] catcher
I just find it jokes I swim silent yeah
that's even cuter
he uh he didn't better than mine yours
is kind of sweet like he didn't quite
get it he was like alright your [ __ ]
quiet okay I had yeah I was the weird
dude that had you on the wall when I was
a kid if that poster could talk
what's wrong with a bed you like I like
the wall if that poster could talk and
if I could get it off the wall that's
haunting I'm good I didn't like solo
that much all right so I recently went
through a very similar heart experience
not quite as severe but 27 I know as
young I was sitting there 47 go this
can't be heart attack I'm 47 so 27 you
must have been like I was like oh she I
mean it wasn't as severe but it was
enough to make me be like I'm coming
Elizabeth it made me really really a lot
of things in my life mainly my creative
process entirely got rewired why I write
what I write why I'm writing is just
completely changed so my question is
Kevin having gone through that has that
rewired your creative process in mark
having watched someone that you're close
with almost leave this world has that
changed how you approach your work at
all for me it didn't change anything to
be honest with you I saw on social media
afterwards people were going like oh
[ __ ] I can't wait to see the next thing
he makes man because [ __ ] he lived and
this is gonna change his perspective is
gonna be profound and deep and the next
thing we're doing is Jay and Silent Bob
rebooted so so much for that [ __ ]
theory I've always kind of conducted
myself and my career
bucket list style like you know clearly
I don't [ __ ] hold back otherwise there
would be no yoga hosers and stuff so I
don't spend my life sitting there going
like ooh I should have or you know if
only I would have I just tend to do it
so there was no moment after nearly
dying where I was like well now it's
time to get [ __ ] serious
about [ __ ] like because I that's my way
of working wouldn't change there was
nothing that I was ever like oh but now
I want to win an Oscar like no it's
business as usual which I guess some
people would find depressing you know
and be like how come you're not taking a
bigger view or some such [ __ ] but I
think it's I've thought about it a great
deal and I think it's largely because I
can't go I can't go for broke more than
I already do you can't like look at tusk
and be like he's playing it safe
you know it's I've always just been that
way so the heart attack didn't change
that for me I'm trying to think what the
heart attack
like did do now three months on like
it's certainly like [ __ ] made me drop
weight and [ __ ] like that made me get
healthy so I'm down like almost 40
pounds now and [ __ ] like it made me
stop eating
you know [ __ ] the animal food
products so I used to be happy now I'm a
[ __ ] vegan and but it was more that
it was more like oh [ __ ] I don't want to
be back here and I don't want to die so
I'll change the way I physically lived
my life but in terms of my work it's so
far it hasn't I haven't seen it have an
effect on that and I think it's because
of the reason I said you you and you
also had a heart Moby heart thing I
think for me there's there's a lot
there's a line in Hamilton because I'm a
oddly Hamilton nerd
he writes day and night like he's
running at a time and I realized five
years ago or so that I had spent most of
my career not doing what I wanted to be
doing you know like it was a journalist
which was great and I had a lot of fun
and I learned a lot but it was never
what I wanted to be doing I wanted to be
doing was making [ __ ] up not reporting
on real [ __ ] that happened facts are for
the weak and so the idea that that I'm
there are fewer days ahead than behind
is real for me in a big bad way
you know just if for no other reason I'm
actually like I should probably be dead
already
why well the life expectancy also the
out of jail expectancy for black men in
America
not overwhelmingly high one in three
black men are behind bars one in ten
don't make it past 40 you know and so
especially coming from the Bronx where I
came from especially my father coming
from Haiti the poorest country in the
Western Hemisphere like I so much of my
life feels like a statistical anomaly as
it is that I'm waiting for that other
shoe to fall because it's been really
good for a really long time so like at
what point will it turn on me hmm and so
the idea that time is not my friend has
been manifestly made real in the last
couple of years and so now it's you've
been waiting too long don't wait anymore
like get it out get it written get it
done what's next done is the engine of
more like what's the next thing
and so mortality in a way has been the
thing and not just his but his was a
giant [ __ ] wake-up call it wasn't
just mine although you know it wasn't it
wasn't a good day of the Sun but the
idea that that there are fewer days
ahead than there are behind or
absolutely making it to that you know
get it done get it done do more every
day you're right like you're running out
of time
amen brother I love that song that's a
great question you get [ __ ] tickets
and a shirt give it up firmly whoever
gets the next shirt gets it sync Marcia
hey how are you I'm good how are you how
what's your name Julia everyone give it
up for Julia Julia is cat ears sisters
she was at the Nationals remember yes
thank you all right I have very easy
going questions no you know what hold on
man that cuz [ __ ] we don't want you
going through life as caddy your sister
cat ears is Julia's sisters so there's a
purple hair valer purple animals yes
purple hair it's different than carriers
we're good it's true you guys he's got
something yes we are you guys are
branding well but I have two questions
because we're a family I want to ask
you're representing the entire
yes I fire away dude let's go yes all
right okay in solo
what makes Chui have a life-debt too
Tahaan makes what she we have a
life-debt to Han so makes him have a
life-debt basically or does he even have
one
basically he could have gotten out of
there was there any reference to never
leaves on you know though I said I'm
just basing it on like you think nice
with the [ __ ] away he even sees other
Chewbacca's or whatever wookies right
yes but yes so they've never expressly
said that he's got a life to have to Han
and there's other wookies yes he could
have he also could escape by himself
totally I'm sorry it's whooping Kashyyyk
Ian I disagree with that
but okay is it because he got him on the
ship baby solo based on so look prior to
solo I would just say it's cuz they're
friends like why why do you hang out why
do holy [ __ ] I can't answer if you keep
talking why does anybody hang out with
anybody you know at a certain point so
at it's a rhetorical question so as a
kid I never questioned I've never needed
a reason why they hung out but not done
yet JC take the mic would you based on
having seen solo if I had to then fly
solo to it I would say because didn't on
technically get Chuy out of a [ __ ]
that's what I'm asking if I had to guess
it would be like these guy because he
[ __ ] saved me from a pit kinda I was
going to beat him but I was going to
yeah but now I'm free okay okay they did
it was a nice rancor monster callback
like where you were like oh [ __ ] he's
gonna there's something giant down there
and there was something giant that's why
I really like their meet-cute like I
didn't see that coming even when they
were like the thing down there's hungry
at 18 18 days I was still like we're
gonna see the
bunkin rancor and like knowing they have
to introduce Chewie sooner or later yeah
it's still such a bad writer I didn't
see it [ __ ] coming and then all of a
sudden you know [ __ ] Chuy's here like
that
so what about you I mean it feels like
it's one of those things that they might
have been counting on a second movie to
help sort of clarify and because it
feels as if they're kind of even by the
end of this particular movie yeah so
unless Chuy's always wanted to also be
the best pilot in the galaxy and i
didn't go back and re-watch but they've
never in tandem pulled those [ __ ]
it's a hand-holding in solo yeah we did
yes let's yeah it was kind of strange
died that seemed added to me like I
didn't think that was they did there
were special modifications that it was
also that Lando [ __ ] a ship which is
another thing what is it that Lando is
[ __ ] in l3 the entire time it works
we just got deep inside right there we
didn't talk about dawn love her that
much no I there's a moment where there's
a couple moments where you just hear him
like there's the Billy Dee sneaking
through and he's trying really like oh
there it is I get it a lot of Cape jokes
which like a couple this keeps your
[ __ ] cool why we got a joke about the
Cape the closet was kind of but yeah I
thought he did good and I thought he
remind both him and the other kid Alden
they reminded me of like the Chris Pine
school of you know did working on
somebody else's character like Chris
Pine is not doing an impression of
William Shatner but his performance
really calls Kirk to mind like and
particularly Shatner's performance of
Kirk so I was now I got lost in my point
yeah I buy this Lando as somebody who
[ __ ] everything yes they really leaned
on heavily in the like pre-release
marketing
Lando [ __ ] everything you hear that
five-second [ __ ] cuz they'll [ __ ] you
they've really sold the pansexuality
they tell you know once again it works
we worked it were made all the money
you'd better buckle up baby mm-hmm
no really the line it works the line
works it all works the line in the movie
it works
purple heroes got a thing for you the
line is literally it works yes how many
times you see this [ __ ] movie night I
thought once I don't remember that at
all robot is talking about Lando and her
he's saying like how it works and she
just says it works
all right now I know because I said it
nine [ __ ] times and I'm never gonna
forget okay question then Oh oh my god
there's a second [ __ ] question I'll
stop talking here we go second question
so at the end of the credits well he
goes back in time yes does all that
stick do you think or is that just for
your entertainment a great question um
it has to stick right but I think it's
weird but if you were ever gonna jam
important information into the
post-credits sequence in an irreverent
way Deadpool is the movie to get away
with it with any other movie I would
have been like are you [ __ ] [ __ ]
me like they didn't wrap this up the way
I wanted them to I thought it was cute
that they wrapped it up at all I thought
when you know cable chose to go back in
time he was gonna go back in time to
that moment where vanessa gets the
spoilers killed but instead he just puts
the coin in his pocket mm-hmm then
leaving the PS sequence of the movie
during the credits to have Deadpool be
like if I fix this thing I can jump all
through time so I think it's I think it
holds okay
I think they absolutely it's part of
their continuity and stuff and I think
very few people could have gotten away
with that but because the nature of that
beast like we let it go I was just
relieved that I left the theater and
they did go back and do that because I
was sitting there gone like you just
broke my travel and [ __ ] like your
knee I'm gonna go back and like
universally eat it I'll be back I'll be
dead one day and then he [ __ ] off so
Kable have gone back in time and killed
a headmaster that's cool yeah lucky that
also would have solved everything
and also like saved a bunch of kids from
being brutalized by an evil headmaster
for decades oh you just made it real man
took a set of comics that took it into
like kids got abused
those were good crushes a great guys
just give it up give it up for Julia and
there's your tickets and get a shirt try
to get one that didn't fall on this
thing all right now that's a clean one
well done man say hi just had ears
filthy all right here we go is that last
question what's your name captain
Michael day everyone give it up for my
goal what's up look born and raised in
this city and this in this [ __ ]
right here yes yeah I could say that cuz
I was born here cuz you were born here
named Natalie let's choose her
transience most of us came here to the
Great Salt Lick but you were born here I
was born in the [ __ ] yeah yeah
unfortunately you know but you know
what's up mark what's that oh hey hey
you guys doing so good yeah borns been
here so long I remember the secret stash
back in the day back in the day when we
were in winter Westwood exactly you
should take the but the number six bus
down there to UCLA to go down there yet
yeah I just remembered only being open
for like a year or something like that
actually I think we made it three years
with three years I'm yeah member was a
short period of time or whatever but I'm
glad 31 is working out and everything
for you or whatever you know yeah sweet
sweet but uh my question is funny you
guys mentioned Logan or whatever at the
end of Logan my favorite character I saw
the Essex symbol on the briefcase
Nathaniel Essex and my question is you
guys know Essex is right exactly one of
my favorite [ __ ] characters who do
you guys think should be playing mr.
sinister if they do end up bringing him
out Jon Hamm really I like that you said
nice to that you're like you didn't
hesitate Smith that was a little too
[ __ ] quick
the [ __ ] gate like I'm truly but fair
my answer every question is jon hamm
yeah yeah okay I mean mr. sinister
that's that's that's it that's a carrot
got a look of that your achter you could
pull that off yeah I think we couldn't
leave ink you could what about you mark
uh I mean I'd be an idiot I didn't say
Jon Hamm clearly a man jump off the ham
wagon there's only room here is enough
room and then a me no no no it's just me
and Jon Hamm [ __ ] off I told you I told
you I creeped him out right like I'm
jogging home wanted a son and we were up
at Sundance an AMC had an event and so
they people who were up at Sundance who
were in other things but also work for
AMC they brought us in to like for like
not the upfront which is kind of like a
publicity event and stuff so Jon Hamm
was there because he was on Mad Men
years ago and stuff I was there because
I was still on comic book men like in
the current and then a few other people
and so I saw Hamm and you know I've met
him at other AMC events and stuff very
nice guy but I've just been deep diving
on a Mad Men again and so when I saw him
like he was the table next to me and we
got reintroduced by Josh escape and a
guy at runs AMC and he goes have you
ever met
Kevin Smith and he goes yes yes man how
are you good to see you guys how are you
sir I said I just wanted to tell you man
I'm deep diving on Mad Men and that
[ __ ] final season like you have some
insane moments man that weird like you
just committed and went there it is so
unbelievably real and I don't identify
with that character but there are
moments where like I feel like oh god
that's a Don Draper s-type [ __ ] I
thought pattern messed up and it's made
me change the way that I conduct my
daily life because I don't ever want to
[ __ ] identify with that character so
I'm going on for good like five and I'm
blazed out of my [ __ ]
yeah and he find that he has the
presence of mind at one point to be like
it was nice talking to you Kevin and
then [ __ ] walked away and I real and
then later on I think and and this is me
putting two and two together but I had
read that he was like trying to be sober
like I think he had went to have or
something so he's trying to put some
drinking behind her something and I
think that as he was sitting there
talking to me he's like clearly he's
[ __ ] high I can't be around this so
you know we just turn in both of in [ __ ]
and so and then I saw him again last
year at IMDb its Sundance when I was
interviewing people and stuff he's
always very sweet dude but yeah I'm a
big [ __ ] fan I think he's I wish
they'd cast him as Batman and Superman
fight each other and love each other
because that's look he's tall okay you
got one I got one
Keanu Reeves oh it's mr. sinister yes
that's [ __ ] good that's better than
mine and and that's coming I think I
think diameter than that one
what you got Javier Bardem oh you beat
us bull man that's [ __ ] a good call
or you're even about the guy that just
like in no country for old man he has
Romania yeah he was literally mr. Sims
yeah yeah sugar they call them sugar in
that sugar and I'm saying also you could
do you know how like Josh Brolin has a
couple characters cable and tunnels for
whatever well if you did like Benicio
del Toro to as like mr. sinister and
have him as the collectors volatility
take that and also we have him in the
Star Wars universe now - he's good in
baseball Taylor yeah he fits that role
he does yeah I'd be all for that and but
you bring up an excellent point which we
didn't really touch on
josh brolin did a phenomenal job with
two separate [ __ ] characters in two
major movie money then a month of each
other man
his thanos performance drives that movie
which should be called not so much
Avengers infinity war as a family
infinity war and his cable performance
was really good like pretty damn strong
and I wonder how that like do you think
there was a discussion at one point like
do you think Marvel was like so we hear
you're gonna be in Deadpool [ __ ]
like we invested a lot of time and money
in you DS or DS that they were just like
go ahead enjoy it's it's not technically
the same thing but even though Marvel
has a title credit before both of them
hmm but I'm sure it was will make all
the money before Deadpool anyway yeah I
guess but it's like you know with all
the [ __ ] actors in the world like you
had to take our Thanos yeah but they got
a lot of nice like shots in there a lot
of Thanos jokes because Ben's alright
that was a great question
and make a great response give it a man
a win tickets and he wins let's do it
your way we'll do the last question last
question because I saw you got upset
when I was like that's a question you're
like hey man I sat through 18 movies for
that post this is Mark's premium one of
the premiums that came from the recent
Marvel marathon movie marathon right I'm
burning everything oh serious yeah so
it's a sign it's a numbers were numbered
print so that's a sweet [ __ ] prize
man do you think you you think you can
earn this oh no I'm nervous basically
you can't [ __ ] this up you could only
lose the poster right well whatever you
ask will be answered but if it's good
enough you're gonna win this sweet
[ __ ] look at that man
a [ __ ] could get laid off a
poster like come into my room let me
show you my marvel 10-year anniversary
poster sit on the bed let's admire it
together put it over the Kevin Smith
post you already have there's only one
of those I heard it's crusty but what do
you paint with that's the question I
[Laughter]
think I gotta live with this come
alright man what is your question
so Star Wars one of the best parts of it
for me is the music okay I am for solo I
it was very unique it was kinda kin as
much as like right now I'm struggling to
remember it so I'm like do you mean
forgettable exactly well I I had the you
would always hear these moments when
somebody come up and you'd hear the TIE
fighter theme and it was oh cool but
there was nothing memorable about it and
I thought that it wasn't Williams it was
another guy and I remember the credit
jeong-ho John Powell John Powell and
themes by John Williams which is gonna
be the way it is from now on like he's
only doing the song I'm curious what
your thoughts are about that if this is
kind of the future what's how that might
affect well think about it in terms of
the heavy lifting has been done and was
done back in the 70s by John Williams he
gave the film's iconic [ __ ] score
that you know somebody just has to do a
few bars and you're like oh that's
[ __ ] Star Wars so there's an argument
to be made of what is Star Wars and and
you know lies you said for you the music
is a big part of it so if you're putting
together a modern-day Star Wars clearly
your themes the theme it's not just the
themes of making the storytelling but
the theme of the movie itself is key to
keeping it within that universe so
stepping back from now I'm not taking
anything away from was his name
well but somebody has created that work
already and then your job is to adapt it
in creative and clever ways so that
people are still getting that constant
influx of Star Wars and and and there
it's subtle like it's not just here's
Han and Chewie in your face but those
themes you know when you hear that and
then like it takes you to a place and
stuff so I don't know that like it's not
is it great for the creativity of the
franchise you know to be like you gotta
do Williams over and over and over again
probably not I bet you you know I'm sure
on some level John Powell was happy to
work with those themes but on another
level it's like boy I wish I could do
what I feel Star Wars is but if you're
gonna go play in their sandbox you got
to play with their toys and stuff so I
think the music's already been
established as far as their concern and
the name of the composer doesn't matter
as much anymore and that's again not
taking anything away from the work of
the composers but for its better for
their branding if everyone just assumes
that it's business as usual and most
people don't stare at the credits that
hard so for most cats they're like well
I'm sure it's the same guy who's been
doing the music all this time and only
those who kind of Becca knew it was John
Powell I keep pointing to him because I
was like my god what a deep cuts
reference and so I for me I can see this
probably is the way that Star Wars goes
from now on it's not going to be like
and this score is gonna be done by this
iconic composer who was the one did rode
warm was it Michael Geoghegan sukhino
and he's kind of like the modern-day
Danny Elfman to a large degrees the guy
that winds up doing a bunch of scores
and stuff I think it'll be like that I
think you're gonna have a lot of
composers who are like the reason I'm a
composer now is because I grew up
listening to John Williams score so
they'll bite at the chance to [ __ ] do
a Star Wars score even though they don't
get to create it whole cloth because
that's part of the fun it's like when I
write a comic book like for Marvel or DC
part of the fun is
you're playing with their [ __ ] toys
but you know part of the understanding
is that you're not going to be able to
do you a hundred percent you're gonna
have to work within there the lines that
they've drawn like you know [ __ ] you
can't expect to write spider-man and
have spider-man called a lizard a [ __ ]
smoker you know they're like we'll let
you play with our characters but you
can't do what you normally do with them
and stuff so I think in the score
departments the same way where it's like
you got a bunch of people who be eager
to jump at Star Wars because that could
score is iconic and they understand
coming in the room that like you're not
going to create the Great American Novel
of music you're gonna do our stuff and
if you find clever ways to make that
Star Wars theme into other things and
score other moments than fantastic but
like save you for other things here you
come to the door you're doing John
Williams that's what feels like to make
you yeah I mean so much of are we
talking about it before that Star Wars
is nostalgia driven Enterprise and so
much of that is there hey don't say Star
Wars an enterprise in the same let's
keep our [ __ ] straight alright I mean
you're not gonna be like adjusting the
phasers density and you're just you're
not gonna be you know bringing the
beaming in new versions of yours number
one stop it - did you do you watch
cinemasins yes so cinemasins if you've
never seen on youtubes it's wonderful I
don't even know how to describe they
essentially take a movie and [ __ ]
show you all the things that don't make
sense or funny or ironic or something
like that but in the cinemasins for the
last Jedi they brought up like he the
guy who hosts it his voice is wonderful
he brought up the fact that he's like is
this the first Star Wars movie where
they bring up the notion of gas of fuel
because like a big part of the plot of
the movie is we got to get away from the
Empire and we only have a little gas
we're gonna slow roll it through space
you know until until the credits so
and he talked about like in the [ __ ]
in the cinemasins that like when did
Star Wars become this grounded in
reality and it reminded me of in the
last Jedi there's also that discussion
about how the people who hate the
x-wings and the people that make the TIE
fighters are the same companies like you
know remember that scene where just like
hey man it's war Bobo has the Benicio
del Toro scene so is weird like they're
introducing like George Lucas you know
like do they ever say how much money Han
Solo got for [ __ ] helping all they
showed was how much to now and 15m did
they say what those two were like it
could have been - shaved wookies and 15
more when we come back right Chewie do
they have a monetary unit in the Star
Wars world right it they just call the
credits so episode where is the most
mundane [ __ ] movie ever know what
it's like we're about taxation routes
and Trade Federation blocking a handsome
and well good snack station where
representation is really [ __ ] shitty
you guys we're gonna go to the Senate
because we got to have government now
because what you really want out of
space operas government it's true yeah
they found a way to make that even less
exciting that it is in the real world
hey kids no it's really exciting yeah I
know you've missed Darth Vader for a
long time kids so here is as a little
boy and he's talking politics enjoy did
you answer Foley but missed aljahmeir
you're like nostalgia I'm done that is a
driver that music is a big tick was your
back brain and suddenly you're there and
you're eight again and suddenly [ __ ] is
awesome it's always gonna be that it's
always gonna be like songs in the key of
Star Wars and not like let's get Daft
Punk
no you're not gonna get def punking you
get some do to get right like John
Williams
let's get Fall Out Boy and we'll have
them redo the theme like they redid that
ghostbusters
yeah man I I think it's I think if you
want to be a creative composer if you
want to show the world something they've
never seen before then you don't go to
star wars like you're to go in there
because you're like I became a composer
because of these movies when I was a kid
or you're like hey I need the money you
know so some people just take the job
for that reason alone but I would assume
most composers given a world of work
they can choose from particularly like
someone like Michael gee he knows how I
pronounce bag dude can do anything he
wants if you're jumping into Star Wars
world you're doing it because you hold
the fection for it and not because
you're like now I'm gonna [ __ ] do
this theme the way it always should have
been done right could you imagine if one
day they released a Star Wars movie and
the big point of contention is like we
change the music like [ __ ] that old
music
it's your Grandpa's music you know so
here's the new Star Wars theme man space
is metal yeah so I would imagine man I'd
imagine it's gonna be it's you know it's
it's that's the way the music will go
for that
oh [ __ ] yeah play the old things play
the [ __ ] Imperial March it's like
going to a Stones concert I just want to
hear the [ __ ] hits action that was a
great question though
so you do get that poster give it up
long way well done man
that yielded a bunch of [ __ ] cool
[ __ ] to talk about we're out of [ __ ] to
give away yeah we're out of questions
we're out of news and that means we're
out of show have you had a good time
ladies and gentlemen
I cannot thank you enough for coming out
we love [ __ ] doing this show it was
hard not to do it for the last few weeks
and stuff so it was great to be back and
doing it and thank God we got a place to
do it at give it up for JC and the scum
and villainy Cantina later not a Star
Wars bar not a Star Wars bar TM just a
bar full of Star Wars enthusiasts and
speaking of Star Wars enthusiasts we
can't do this show without the man
standing to my left give it up for mr.
mark Bernard man and that is fat man on
Batman for this week I'm Kevin Smith
I am mark [ __ ] in tune in next week
same fad time same fat channel SModcast
calm or youtube.com slash Kevin Smith
good night everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
you